2020 vision couldn't have seen how
unconventional this year would look
convention is now history drop to the
balloons
banners buttons walter we're told that
when this antenna starts turning you go
all the way to the ceiling
headsets hats and horns
gone is the suspense that once got
reporters like dan rather
swept up don't push me take your hands
off of me that was 1968.
ted koppel began covering conventions
even earlier it was
exciting there was stuff going on like
1980 when the race for ronald reagan's
running mate went down to the wire
suddenly at the very last moment and one
of the biggest scoops in convention
history
belonged to our leslie stahl a top
lieutenant just came and said
it's not for they're coming all around
me to tell me it's not ford someone told
me it was bush
i turned around and i said can i go with
that he said it's solid
it's gold-plated they're all yelling
bush all around me
everybody's healing bushwalder i
remember
how excited i was to break that story it
was the only story at that convention
do you think they still serve a useful
purpose at all no
ted koppel came to that conclusion in
1996 at the republican convention i
realized it was going to be
exactly as scripted as predictable
as boring and we agreed it was a waste
of time we hung up a sign that said gone
fishing
we have to be there that's always been
sort of the pack mentality that's
exactly why i left
we didn't have to be there has your view
on them changed at all since then
they've gotten worse still one line
sometimes
sticks remember these read my
lips
poor george he was born with a silver
foot in his mouth
you know they say the difference between
a hockey mom and a pit bull
lipstick and some speeches are
remembered for the wrong reason
like then governor bill clinton in 1988
who went on twice as long as scheduled
his biggest applause line
in closing
it is certainly one speech that michael
dukakis should have no trouble topping
just four years later clinton was the
comeback kid and the nominee
i still believe in a place called
hope john kerry believes in 2004 then
state senator barack obama
also spoke of hope the hope of a skinny
kid
with a funny name who believes that
america has a place for him too
and you know what happened next thank
you but as joe biden joined hands with
barack obama before 80 000 cheering fans
and four years later clint eastwood
unloaded on an empty chair
what do you mean shut up no one could
have guessed that
this time there would be an empty hall
so with these conventions
don't expect anything quite like this
it won't be fun they were so much fun
and i don't mean just for me i think the
audience
watched the craziness and the audience
enjoyed that